hey everyone and welcome to another
episode of generation next or should i
say
generation now no no no no
no just really pulled the rug out from
under my feet there
but anyway this week we're going to be
discussing all of the uh
issues that people have been reporting
with their brand new xbox series x's and
playstation 5. that's right both xbox
and sony have reported issues with their
brand new consoles so to discuss
i'm joined by xbox expert jordan remain
what's up
and playstation pro hussein hi everyone
how are you doing today
what what i
i'm waiting now for the other shoe to
fall
yeah it's like halfway through the
episode or something
the consoles are out it's done you don't
have to be horny for next-gen anymore
no more it's done we're here okay
i don't trust this i don't trust this
this definitely feels like
some kind of it's always sunny like
like a scheme but
anyway lads let's talk about broken
consoles
[Music]
okay let's start with playstation 5. um
i didn't flip a coin or anything it's
just because there seemed to be way more
issues with the playstation 5
uh or at least well uh way more widely
reported issues
so let's start this isn't even really an
issue because
it's kind of like a small win but the
absolute bands of sony accidentally
sending people
disc versions of ps5s when they bought
digital copy
digital versions just save 100 on it
just
easy safe yeah i mean it is good in
in for like the money you save but also
there might be some people who are like
i've got that version because it fits in
a certain way into my
entertainment center because i don't
know what i've got
yeah i've got the the playstation with
the absolute back off
and now i'm worried what am i going to
do but the great
british back off yeah my i mean
the one thing i'll say about this before
we move on because it's a very quick
note is that if something were to go
wrong with those consoles
i really hope the retailer like is
okay with it because if there's if
they're trying to do a repair
hey your receipt says ps5 digital
edition but you're sending us a ps5 disk
edition
um i think uh based on people who have
had this situation
happen um the serial numbers do match
okay so it's just a kind of it's just a
weird situation where
some of these consoles are appearing
with the right serial numbers but the
wrong
model sounds strange but
let's let's talk about the thing that
has really dominated the discussion this
week
i don't think i've ever heard the phrase
rest mode
uh as much as i have this week tam you
want to give us the overview
of what's been happening like many of us
living through the current day and age
where
these strange and unusual times yeah
they play like us
the playstation 5 is like crashing in
rest mode
um uh so the the uh
the issue kind of is has been reported a
bunch of places i know from us we picked
up on it not picked up on it but
our first kind of exposure to it was
giant bomb um
friend of shows uh in the family very
own um
jeff gerstmann who tweeted about the bug
and it's basically when you
when he put the rest the console into
rest mod while playing spider-man
remastered
and it crashed the entire system and
then
following up to that we had our very own
curt indivina um
who lost two hours of demon souls
progress
when his console was
i know kurt was kurt was distraught but
all i'm going to say is like her grow up
just get out of the game two hours is
nothing
that's a quick run just go for the legs
bring him down stab him in face move on
regulations
are just features yeah this is just an
extra challenge
um no but seriously that sucks but
there's also been like issues with
sinking cloud saves yeah i saw a tweet
about someone
like platinuming i think it was miles
morales
and then they had the rest mode bug that
crashed and then their save didn't sink
yeah so did they stop the plat or did
they no they they got a lot of
it wasn't actually like um platinuming
it it was got most of the way to it
and then and then like refreshed it
and oh that's even worse yeah so like
kurtz one was um he his one
he put it on rest mode and then when he
tried to turn it on it had shut off
in the background um and his controller
didn't connect it was as if it was
unpaired
and then when he turned it on it was
having issues syncing his cloud
um saves um so that's something that i
have had as well like cloud save syncing
issues where i'll turn it on and it's
like
hey we can't sync this save file so
luckily it hasn't been a crash so i
think you can go and then force a manual
sync as well
which is what i did um but like if
you're if it screws up
where and you're and you're just
completely unaware and you don't get
that option that really really sucks
um however sony has released an update
so before we get on to the update we
need to talk about some of the other
issues that people have had
so there have been charging issues with
using the front ports the front usb
port people are reporting that the dual
sense just isn't charging
and getting to full battery um
the the reason i wanted to talk about
this before we talked about the update
is because
the ps4 the ps5 has a really irritating
uh
preference where it keeps trying to get
the ps4 version of a game so if you have
a game
um like call of duty black ops gold or
card blocks cow
it will try it will download the ps4
version fine
and it'll keep trying to default to that
one cali had that issue
uh multiple people have had that issue
um
kind of funny has had that issue yeah
it's such a weird thing that i didn't
think that
xbox's smart delivery was going to be
this huge thing that would just be
easy across both systems but
surprisingly it's like oh no
sony didn't handle this super well on
the playstation side
it's been very very strange but uh
another thing so defaulting to the ps4
version like there is a
there is a workaround to make sure
you're playing the right version of the
game but the other thing is there has
been a
download queue bug um
this one happened to me with ghost of
sushima actually but there has been
um there's an article over on ign by by
friend of the show
uh joe scrabbles who basically like apps
will get caught in this weird state
where it says that it's queued for
download and then you get this download
error
and he had this issue and multiple
people over there have had that
the issue where cod will download the
ps4 version
fine and then just refuse to download
the ps5 version
so sony issued the patch um
which didn't specifically state what it
was fixing but it was like 900 megabytes
and it said this system software update
import
improved system performance um so people
are reporting that it should be
a lot better to you know the firmware
hopefully should be more stable now
it should hopefully charge but joe
scrabbles did a follow-up and said that
that patch didn't fix
the download cue book so that is
disappointing strange
and i think he said that he's still
actually unable to play the ps5 version
of god
yeah that is extremely unfortunate but
not entirely unexpected yeah um
i know we'll get on to like whether we
should be worried or not but
the important like the thing that gives
me solace is
how much of this is software side how
much of this is hardware side
the former is easier to deal with than
the latter
and there are certainly some hardware
issues out and about for the playstation
as well
i mean i know personally at least one
person my roommate who has a
non-functioning disk drive
on the playstation 5 um which is oh
that's sucks
and the tricky thing around um hardware
issues is
the process of go you know sending it
back to sony or
or a retailer and getting it back is one
difficult to
there's not a lot of ps5s available so
what do you do
and i hope that sony is taking measures
to
communicate itself and to retailers that
they're gonna extend the warranty period
and um like make sure that when they are
freely available like they're not
telling people oh you bought this at
launch so you're outside of the period
that you know
yeah we can fix that for you um sony are
generally okay with it if you reach out
to them directly
um they're quite communicative um so
hopefully that is the case here
i also i i will say like
it's it's you do take a gamble being an
early adopter of any
new piece of hardware and i think the
conversation where it's like
you made a mistake you should never
thanks for beta testing it for us
those people need to grow oh my god
that's probably one of the most
exhaustive like
just bad takes that i think i've seen
it's like
what you want to do like we're in a
place now especially now
where if you can't play something like
if you're
super super passionate about playing a
certain game like that that's gonna get
spoiled for you
like with the with twitter with social
media with youtube with
clickbait youtube thumbnails that show
you the endings of games like
yeah some people if they are able to
want to be first in line and play those
games and
you know have saved their money and you
know
so being being doesn't help anyone yeah
grow up
so playstation a lot of issues
so far i i will say that mine has mine's
crashing a lot
um which has been
it's been okay it's mostly been like
games that are crashing but then
they'll boot up really quickly and so
it's not
i don't know i think the one considering
the one question a lot of people might
be watching this and
having is like why didn't any of this
come out in the review phase
um because it wasn't happening it's
important to know that this wasn't the
case in the review phase which is why it
leads me to believe that this is a
software focus thing
like um the playstation 5 itself up
until it became
more available in certain territories
basically launch
was perfectly stable for me and i'm not
sure if that was the case for lucy as
well but i had zero crashes
i had no crashes yeah our reviewer was
like reported
like no crashes maybe like one that felt
like it was just
a buildup and overload kind of thing but
nothing
noticeable i had no issues with it and
the same thing happened to me with demon
souls like i had demon souls
slightly earlier than um like most
like six a.m day off yeah six am so like
most people
got it a few hours later and it was fine
um
that entire first day when you know a
lot of people didn't have it
and then the day after when it had
launched and people were starting to
play it and more people were playing it
that's when all the crashes started to
happen
um so and it was also i think it might
have more to do with the software side
of stuff
um so if you're wondering why wasn't
this quarter in the review phase it's
because
it wasn't there at that point um and it
does feel like something that should be
fairly easy to solve for sony
and hopefully yeah we're under we're
understating how much work goes into
creating
firmware updates and you know certifying
them testing them and then getting them
out
but relatively speaking a firmware
update to address this stuff
is probably going to be more manageable
than oh crap
we we've got bad silicon in this or you
know the power management screw
etc etc all right it's time to go over
to xbox
who have also had some issues uh
jordan you want to give us the top level
stuff about what's been going on
yeah so xbox hasn't had as
many issues i think as playstation 5 but
they're pretty
severe i think the biggest one has been
with the disc drive
on the series x it creates this like
some people are reporting this
loud grinding uh evan
please put the video in i'll link it i
didn't
realize this was an issue
i need to put a disc into my xbox to see
if it does
yeah i i haven't actually tried my disk
drive yet so i have no idea if i have
this
issue or not i was watching uh my
brother my brother and me
the tv show on dvd the other day and
mine
luckily was fine and so i didn't hear
anything about
um disk drives until a few days ago and
i was like oh my god
it's uh quite loud quite pronounced it
just sounds like it's uh
i don't know tunneling underground or
something
disgusting sound but hopefully it's
fixed
like the disk drives for ps5 uh the
other issues
aren't as severe and i assume
will be smaller fixes there has been
some wi-fi
uh connectivity issues people have been
reporting that the console just
disconnects from wi-fi or just doesn't
uh
connect at all some games are getting
some error messages
there was this really weird report of
someone
starting their xbox and like the console
essentially just
crashed and there were like a bunch of
these green dots on
oh i saw that one when he was trying to
play card i think
i think so yeah oh night vision mode
[Laughter]
i've seen a lot of reports of people are
having issues with
power that seems to be so there's
obviously reset era threads there's
tweets there's reddit posts um
a friend of the show friend of the
podcast this isn't a podcast i just love
saying that phrase
uh blessing over it kind of funny has
had to send his xbox
back um he oh i feel so bad for him he
said he got to play like four hours of
yakuza and then
it just died and he did the factory
reset
and it just didn't work got through a
whole single chapter then
oh god that game is so good i know this
isn't really the place to talk about it
but god yeah sound like a dragon is
really good
there are a lot of issues going around
with both of these consoles
like we're not leaning in one way or
another to say like this worse than
the other one it's just it's like lucy
said these are the kind of things that
do happen
with early hardware and um
with every like new generation of
console
the people who are purchasing them are
more connected more vocal
and more readily available to report
issues
so we're just getting flooded with
instances of this happening people are
one reporting them to we live in a world
where creating content around them does
you know numbers so people i mean
i've seen some fake videos that i'd be
like my xbox
pulled out a gun and shot me and it's
like what are you talking about man
and like other vaping
yeah i guess the point is like yes there
are issues out there
and keep an eye out for them because
they are genuine but also don't get
debated by people being like my
xbox slept with my girlfriend and and my
playstation
and now with now i've had to have a
divorce look at my thumbnail
like that kind of what it's like
there's loads of that going around just
like what's going on here i know what
you're trying
just people making [ __ ] up and just
putting it on the internet
like a bad ah slash relationships pose
yeah just like absolute blatant lies
like my xbox exploded my playstation
the screws fell out at once and you're
like oh relax
man no one's believing this i mean it is
unfortunate and
if you are having those issues um
definitely
immediately report them to microsoft and
sony they
unfortunately both of them have
extensive experience
in you know hardware software that
doesn't necessarily work
i mean xbox one had the restarts and had
the grinding noises
the rendering of death sony had uh
the little online snafu 2011.
so the yellow light of death as well and
the yellow lion they've all had their
quirks
all hardware has its quirks um but i
can't we kind of
talked about it so it's like should you
be worried honestly
i think at the end of the day you kind
of have to take into account that it's a
global pandemic
things will move slower but at the end
of the day i really hope
the customer service on both sides sorts
everyone out i think as well
they know what these issues are they are
actively working
probably around the clock to fix them
especially on the
software side firmware side so it
sucks that it's happening but it's not
like they're just putting stuff out
there and forgetting about them yeah
it's gonna be worse
both microsoft and sony said that
they're working on solutions not like
just leaving the consoles to die okay
bye
i will say despite all these problems i
am absolutely swinging with these two
consoles lads
and they are incredible having both of
them has been
back
um it's been yeah it's been fantastic
like obviously all sympathy for
for the people who are having trouble
right now but you know
there's also a bunch of people that are
having a great time with these consoles
playstation 5 has been incredible
i wrote my demon souls review um and
it's up and that game is phenomenal
um miles is great jordan's review is up
for it
astrobot is such a fun game sackboy is
amazing
sackboy is getting slept on i'm
surprised i'm surprised with how much
i'm enjoying both astrobot and sackboy
both of them are like these really
adorable platforms
yeah exactly um bug snacks is so much
fun
and um i'm playing like overwatch on
there and it's quicker and the xbox you
know
um yakuza amazing like really really fun
game getting real sucked into it and i'm
like dipping into older games that are
available on game pass and
just xbox works with and it's such a
good time
to be playing games and after the year
that it has
been having these new toys to play with
and being reminded about why games are
so much fun and how much fun you can
have with them has been so valuable
um i hope the people that are having
trouble have them resolve quickly
because you know
there's so much to enjoy right now and
there will be like the future of
these consoles are super bright hell
yeah wow that was a very positive note
to everyone
um if you've been having issues with
your consoles let us know in the
comments below
um and fingers crossed everything gets
resolved soon
we'll be back again next week and
hopefully with a it was a brighter
episode
hopefully hopefully we'll see you then
you